RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTER SAID
HIS COUNTRY MIGHT HELP IN THE
INVESTIGATION.
RUSSIA DENIED INVOLVEMENT.
THESE ARE THE MOST DESPERATE
TIMES IN VENEZUELA.
THE ECONOMY IS COLLAPSING.
POVERTY IS SKY ROCKETING.
THAT'S LEADING MANY TO ABANDON
HOPE AND LEAVE.
RICH TELLS US ABOUT IT TONIGHT
FROM THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> DESPERATE FOR FOOD AND
MEDICINE, THOUSANDS FROM
VENEZUELA CROSS INTO COLUMBIA.
>> WE ARE STAFFERING.
-- STARVING.
WE ARE DIEING OF HUNGER.
>> THEY ARE SLEEPING ON THE
TREATS.
>> THE BILLS ARE NOT WORTH
ANYTHING.
JUST PAPER.
>> INFLATION IN VENEZUELA WILL
RISE 13,000% AND THE ECONOMY
SHRINKS 15%.
MORE THAN 4 IN 10 IN VENEZUELA
WANT TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY
PERMANENTLY.
VIOLENCE AND HUNGER HAVE
OVERCOME THE COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT IS STILL PURSUING
REELECTION IN MAY.
>> WE ARE UNDER PRESSURE BUT
VENEZUELA IS BASED ON
PRINCIPALS.
>> THE UNITED STATES CALLED THAT
MAY 20th ELECTION ILLEGITIMATE
AND CONSIDERING SANCTIONS.
>> WE HAVE SEEN THE REPEATED
ELECTIONS WHERE THE REGIME
PUSHED PEOPLE TO VOTE A CERTAIN
PAY.
OUR CONCERNS REMAIN ABOUT THE
EROSION OF DEMOCRACY IN THAT
COUNTRY.
>> IT'S MORE DIFFICULT FOR
VENEZUELA RESIDENTS TO LEAVE
THEIR COUNTRY.
>> I HOPE THEY DON'T DEPORT ME.
I DON'T KNOW WHEN I WANT TO GO
BACK TO VENEZUELA.
I PLAN TO STAY HERE WORKING TO
ACHIEVE A BETTER LIFE FOR MY
CHILDREN.
>> THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
RESULT SEEMS PRE-DETERMINED.
THE PRESIDENT THEY SAY RIGGED
THE SYSTEM AND THEY REFUSE TO